so I've given up on comic book movies
and I started watching anime and
Kenpachi from bleached is a beast this
guy makes Ichigo look like a joke like
really early on he just casually
teleports behind him and then just
proceeds to toy with the kid while
Ichigo fights for his goddamn life he's
so strong that he stops ichigo's sword
with just his residual energy the guys
flash buildings in two multiple times
he's been shown to fight off other Soul
Society captains with little to no
effort he's blocked in no soul attacks
that took out the entire main cast with
ease and funny enough that's when he's
just holding back after taking off his
eye patch and then learning how to
properly use a shikai he transcends the
abilities of normal Soul Reapers and
once he's reached his bonkai he was able
to kill Gerard a man whose ability was
to literally summon Miracles he killed a
guy that had the power of plot armor and
I don't even know how somebody does that
make sure you guys follow for more